EAMMON WEED: My
name is Eammon Weed,
and I am a sophomore currently
studying history and English.
Interestingly enough,
four years ago,
I had the delight of meeting
this afternoon's speaker
at the Acton Institute, when I
was a sophomore in high school.
And it was by mere
coincidence that I was
asked to introduce him today.
And so, it is with
great pleasure
that I introduce our next
speaker, Dr. Glenn Arbery.
Dr. Glenn C. Arbery
is the president
of Wyoming Catholic College.
He earned his PhD in
literature and politics
from the University of Dallas.
He has taught at the University
of St. Thomas, Thomas Moore
College of Liberal Arts,
the University of Dallas,
and Assumption College,
where he held the d'Alzon
Chair of Liberal Education.
He has served as Director
of the Teachers Academy
at the Dallas Institute
of Humanities and Culture
and as an editor of the
People Newspapers in Dallas,
where he won regional
and national awards
for his writing.
In addition to numerous
essays and reviews,
Dr. Arbery is the
author or editor
of Why Literature Matters, The
Southern Critics, The Tragic
Abyss, and Augustine's
Confessions and its Influence.
Please join me in
welcoming Dr. Arbery.
[APPLAUSE]
GLENN ARBERY: Eamonn
reminded me last night
when I saw him that I tried to
recruit him to Wyoming Catholic
College four years ago.
I'm glad now that we
didn't get him, since--
that's not a coincidence.
How could that be a
coincidence, right?
These things come around.
About 25 years ago, Jeff Nelson,
at the Intercollegiate Studies
Institute called me
up one day to ask me
if I would write a book
about why literature matters.
Foolishly, I agreed to do it.
And now, every few years
I get an invitation
from someone who hopes I have
by now figured out what to say.
This time it was my old
friend Doug Jeffrey.
When we were at the
University of Dallas,
he drove if not the only, at
least the coolest Karmann Ghia
in Dallas County.
He persuaded me, during
the blank-eyed lulls
of writing my
dissertation, to read
the novels of Ross
MacDonald, which I remember
with particular gratitude.
I add to it my gratitude for
this invitation to Hillsdale
College, which has been
a beacon of independence
in American thought,
like the signal flare
that Homer describes late in
The Iliad that goes pulsing
high for men of the neighboring
islands to see it in case
they might come over in ships
to help beat off the enemy.
The question, why
literature matters,
comes up now once again in the
context of liberal education.
Even before there were
academies of course,
poetry formed the minds
of those who heard it.
And literature has
been, from the beginning
of the Western
tradition, a central way
of educating the young and
enlightening their elders.
But at least since
Plato, it has also
been suspect
because of its power
in forming opinion without the
authority of careful argument.
So what is this
continuing appeal?
It's not merely entertainment,
though it unquestionably
gives pleasure.
Even now, literature
is a common language
for those who are
educated, and an ability
to move gracefully among
literary references
to poems, novels, and plays,
adds to beauty of character.
Why literature matters
today, however,
becomes a particularly
pressing question
when we think about the
graceless controversies that
surround it, when it
is treated primarily
as an ideological tool.
Back in December, a
piece about #DisruptTexts
by Meghan Cox Gurdon of
the Wall Street Journal
caused a stir when it exposed
the dismissal of The Odyssey
by a high school
in Massachusetts.
Very proud to say
we got The Odyssey
removed from the curriculum
this year, one teacher declared.
The teachers in
Massachusetts apparently
believed that the longer ago
the now banished Odyssey was
written, the more
objectionable it was.
They must have imagined an
outbreak of hurtful cyclops
jokes.
[LAUGHTER]
Perhaps the harsh judgment of
the marginalized lotus-eaters
offended them.
In any case, there's
nothing new in their attempt
to get the classics
out of the curriculum.
The famous, "hey, hey,
ho, ho, Western culture's
got to go" protest about the
civilization course at Stanford
occurred in 1987.
And I remember a
conference at LSU in 1991
when a cadre of college
teachers would not
read The Aeneid,
for the seminar,
because it would be collusion
in the European colonization
of Latin America.
This is sensitive stuff.
So better not read
The Odyssey either.
According to disrupt
text, young people
should read only works written
in the present day vernacular,
works that promote
and center voices that
are LGBQTIA plus and BIPOC,
Black indigenous and People
of Color.
There are many
reasonable answers,
many reasons why it's important
to keep great literature
in the curriculum, especially
when it requires a challenging
encounter with
unfamiliar language.
Reading a deeply
engaging work, older
by far than the
political structures
and racial divisions
of the Western world,
one that precedes Socrates,
Plato, and Aristotle
by centuries, not to
mention, Rome, Christian
Europe, and the
Americas might begin
to overcome what
Alan Tate described
as provincialism in time--
the belief that this
moment of history
is the judge of all others.
Roger Kimball last night
described it as presentism.
The sociologist Peter
Berger diagnosed
the essential complaint
against the classics,
50 years ago, in the 1970
essay called The Obsolescence
of the Concept of Honor.
He'd just
distinguished societies
based on clear roles--
for example, the warrior
world of The Iliad
from modern ones
based on dignity,
understood as
intrinsic humanity,
divested of all socially
imposed roles or norms.
As Berger explains, looking
back from his perspective
on the 1960s, quote,
"The social location
of honor in a
world of relatively
intact stable institutions, a
world in which individuals can
with subjective certainty
attach their identities
to the institutional roles
that society assigns to them."
This is what he understands
by the world of honor.
For example, in
a world of honor,
a poet would find writing
an ode or a sonnet part
of the role of being a poet.
He or she would find
it an opportunity
for demonstrating
individual poetic talent,
in measuring mastery
of a challenging
form against past writers.
Even romantic revolutionaries
like Shelley wrote sonnets.
In societies that reject
honor, on the other hand,
institutions- this is Berger--
"Cease to be the
home of the self.
Instead they become
oppressive realities that
distort and estrange the self.
Roles no longer
actualize the self,
but serve as a veil of
Maya, hiding the self
not only from others,
but from the individual's
own consciousness."
End quote.
In other words, the coercive
demands of the sonnet
distort or silence
self expression.
And the poet should reject
any social role that requires
submission to such forms.
So, for contemporary
movements like disrupt text,
the honored works of
the Western tradition
have become institutional
forms, imposed by those
who control the cannon--
oppressive realities from
which students must be
liberated in order to find
their own voices and identities.
Berger strikes me as
particularly pressing it
when he writes that
the individual who
rejects the world
of honor can only
hope to define himself quote,
"in the interstitial spaces
left vacant by
the institutions."
For example, as self expression
and gender identity moves
away from all socially
imposed roles or norms,
it's literature
tries to dissolve
any standard of excellence
not based on dignity
or individual self expression.
Ironically, what this
means in practice
is that writers supposedly
in the cultural interstices
win literary prizes and
prestigious university
positions that honor dissent
as a new social norm, which
makes it hard to describe
these writers as anything
but the new
institutional mainstream.
One gets confused.
But let's avoid the
sirens of grievance.
Two reasons that
literature matters
seem to me most pressing.
One, is what my teacher at the
University of Dallas, Louise
Cowan, called cosmopoiesis,
or world-making,
in her introduction to
the epic cosmos in 1984.
The second involves
literature as the mode
of concrete or embodied thought,
most natural to the human mind.
That is, thinking in images,
comparisons, characters,
speeches, and actions.
The characters and
actions of literature
are offered to the common
judgment of mankind.
The best works endure
because they most wisely
represent human
and divine things
and give us the pleasure of
recognizing our lives in more
noble contours.
Let me start with the
second, literature
as a mode of thought.
Every household of
parents and children
has a cast of
distinct characters
whose various performances
become stories in the family.
One of our four-year-old
grandsons for example,
though a domestic
terrorist by day,
sang a beautiful solo of
Silent Night on Christmas Eve,
much to our astonishment.
Every classroom could
provide Ben Johnson
with examples of the
humors and so could
every day in an office.
Anyone engaged in making, excuse
me, in managing other people
thinks in characters
and actions.
Who's brave enough
to risk the boss'
rage over a personal fault
that's hurting the company?
What will Grove do to
handle this slight?
Did you see how Pritchett
treated that woman?
How do you think Clotka
will react when we
present this proposal to her?
This way of thinking
is so natural to us
that we hardly consider
it thought at all.
And attempts to
reduce it to a system,
say in the scenarios of
business advice books,
always seem naive.
The philosopher himself,
as Dante calls him,
bases his account of virtue
in the Nicomachean Ethics
not on a set of principles, but
on the character and actions
of the spoudaios, the
serious admirable man
imitated by those who want to
exhibit courage or prudence.
Novels, plays, and epics,
work through the depiction
of character.
At the beginning of The Iliad,
for example, only Achilles
will stand up to Agamemnon
when he brings down
a plague on the entire army.
And only Achilles suffers the
mortal insult of the king.
Through his mother, Achilles
asked Zeus for the honor
that Agamemnon has denied
him, even though it
will mean the deaths of many and
the defeat of his own friends.
Both men bring harm to their
own army, in other words.
But which is more noble,
Agamemnon or Achilles?
For anyone who's read
The Iliad, the answer
is obviously Achilles.
Saying why takes the reader
into the depths of the poem.
Later in The Iliad, the
Achaeans have been driven back
inside their newly built
wall and the Trojans
occupy the whole plain.
Diomedes volunteers to find out
how the Trojans are arranged
and what their plans might be.
Who does he want with him on
this dangerous night raid?
Nestor?
Huge Ajax?
Menelaus?
No, he wants Odysseus.
And so would you.
The judgment is instantaneous.
Why?
He had to tease it out.
You'd say that unexpected
situations don't rattle him,
that he's quick-witted
and physically powerful,
and that he's a superb liar.
We naturally condense what
a person says and does,
as well as what other
people say about him,
into a single charged
image of who he or she is.
It can be wrong.
It often is wrong.
And this possibility
of error also
forms part of what
literature shows.
King Lear banishes the
daughter who loves him most.
Othello is so wrong
about Desdemona,
thinking that she has shamed
him and his culture of military
honor, that he
cannot let her live.
But even as he kills her,
he adores her, praises her,
tries to save her
from damnation.
After he kills her, he discovers
her innocence and cries,
Whip me, you devils,
from the possession
of this heavenly sight.
Blow me about and winds,
roast me in sulfur.
Wash me in steep down
gulfs of liquid fire.
Othello becomes for
us a figure embodying
many cultural complexities,
a part of our thought.
Like him, hundreds of other
characters from literature
become part of the way we
think, as though we knew them
personally--
Clytemnestra, Penelope, Dido,
Cordelia, Hester Prynne.
Literature helps form
judgment and right feeling.
In fact, it helps us
order experience itself.
The accuracy of
its depictions may
be constantly tested
against people
we know, or might come to know.
As a teacher, it
never occurs to me
to try to abstract a
concept from characters
like Raskolnikov, Captain
Ahab, or Don Quixote,
as though they merely
stood for something
that could be more
tidily handled
on the conceptual level.
In 19th century St.
Petersburg, Raskolnikov
lives in a milieu of
radical social thought.
And his mind has been formed
by fashionable theories.
But unlike many others,
he feels the compulsion
to test himself by putting
these theories into action.
There's a kind of
integrity in that,
even though it involves
killing an old pawnbroker.
But he therefore suffers
the full consequences
of what he does.
A student learns Raskolnikov--
not a concept that he stands
for, and not even really
the character Raskolnikov,
as though he were merely
an exhibit of the
novelist's imagination.
Knowing Raskolnikov
pulls the reader
into the whole rich, social,
and spiritual context
of Dostoevsky's novel.
Great characters, like
people we've known deeply
in our lives, become complex
attractors that order
and deepen daily understanding.
Literature leads us into
thinking more deeply
in and through our
own experience.
Literature is a
mode of knowledge.
It also involves a deep
pleasure in language itself--
this would be a good
time to put up the poem--
in the revelation of likenesses.
For example, Gerard
Manley Hopkins,
in his sonnet, The
Starlight Night,
thinks in a series of
metaphors about the stars.
His language is dense
with illiteration,
full of heavy stresses that
form a kind of counterweight
to the upward vision, and all
of this in the imperative mood.
Imagine a student
used to reading works
in the present day vernacular
suddenly buttonholed
by Hopkins' poem.
"Look at the stars!
Look, look up at the skies!
Oh, look at all the
fire-folk sitting in the air!
The bright boroughs, the
circle-citadels there!
Down in dim woods
the diamond delves!
The elves'-eyes!
The grey lawns cold where
gold, where quickgold lies!
Wind-beat white beam!
Airy abeles set on a flare!
Flake-doves sent floating
forth at a farmyard scare!
Ah well!
It is all a purchase,
all is a prize.
Buy then!
Bid then!
What?
Prayer, patience, alms, vows.
Look, look, a May-mess
like on orchard boughs!
Look!
March-bloom, like on
mealed-with-yellow sallows!
These are indeed the barn;
withindoors house the shocks.
This piece-bright
paling shuts the spouse.
Christ home, Christ and his
mother and all his hollows."
Now we could pause over
the word quickgold, which
Hopkins invented, according to
the Oxford English Dictionary.
Quicksilver we know.
It's the older and more
descriptive term for mercury
and it's kind of
jittery liveliness.
So we make the transfer and see
the gray lawns cold where gold,
where quickgold lies.
The cold dew drops quick
with the golden sunlight
on the lawns.
The stars become the features
of this kind of English estate.
They flare like white beam
leaves tossed by the wind.
They burst into sight like
doves scared up from a farmyard.
And this estate is for sale.
Hopkins tells us,
buy then, bid then.
Buy with what?
With prayer,
patience, alms, vows.
Again, he commands us to look.
In the last metaphorical
transformation,
the whole sky of
the starlight night
becomes a single structure
if you follow what
he's doing in this last part.
These are indeed the barn,
that is the whole night
sky you're looking at.
Is to be conceived
as the single barn.
And inside the barn
are the sheaves
stored up after the harvest,
the gathered saints, let's say.
Remember the old song,
Bringing in the Sheaves?
But these are also--
notice the enjambment.
Notice the way that the
shocks is left there
at the beginning of that
next to the last line.
The greatest shocks are those of
the unexpected, surpassed hope
or understanding.
The greatest shock of
all is the last image
of immense interior
light, pouring out
through the tiny gaps and holes
in the palings of the house,
of this barn that houses
Christ and his mother in all
his hollows, as though the
whole starry sky were simply
a vision of that light breaking
through in these tiny places.
Why this repeated demand to
look as though we had never
seen the skies?
The Russian critic,
Viktor Shklovsky
wrote a century
ago that perception
can become so habitual that
it becomes algebraization.
Wordsworth complains, little
we see in nature that is ours.
But Hopkins shocks us, out
of laying waste our powers.
Look at the stars.
Look, look up at the skies.
He also shocks us
from the way that we
see dew or wind blown
trees or the flowers
on spring orchard boughs.
Thinking in
metaphors, we discover
the beauty of familiar things
put next to each other.
As Hopkins says
in another sonnet,
beauty keeps warm men's
wits to the things that are.
Now, this in itself is
already an accomplishment.
By the late 19th century
when Hopkins is writing,
time and space
and divine purpose
had all suffered major
shocks from modern science.
The deep time of geology,
the increasing vastness
of the discoverable universe,
the apparently random
adaptation of creatures
to environments
in Darwin's theories of
evolution, and in general,
a de-centering of man
and the human intellect,
and a disenchanting of the world
outside the Cartesian subject.
So what Hopkins is
doing here is a bid
toward that other dimension of
literature that I think we see,
and what Louise Cowan calls
world-making, or cosmopoiesis.
This cosmos, this world
that the poet makes,
as Louise Cowan says,
"establishes the mundus
imaginalis wherein reside
the universal qualities that
make up the human condition.
It's the glory of
the poetic cosmos
to show these verities in
action, embedded in matter,
bearing the weight
and expressing
the hope of the finite
order," end quote.
A poetic cosmos is
a whole apprehended
by the imagination, everywhere
charged with meaning--
a lived world of sky
and earth; the living
and the dead, cities and
households, gods and mortals.
It's an interpretive
order, a felt world
that gives a place to the whole
realm of human experience.
World-making doesn't
mean rhetorically
affirming the structures and
institutions that are already
there so much as it
means subjecting them
to poetic revision and scrutiny.
For example, think what
Homer does in both The Iliad
and The Odyssey.
Agamemnon's outrageous
insult to Achilles
calls into question the
justice of awarding or denying
honors when the standards
of the one in charge
are personal or
politically biased.
Suppose that someone's greatness
exceeds the city's capacity
to contain it in its
system of social roles
and conventional honors.
Does such greatness destroy
the city or transfigure it?
That's the question
that The Iliad poses.
In The Odyssey, marriage
undergoes a major reimagining.
The reunion of
Odysseus and Penelope
doesn't restore
something normal.
I think we tend to
think that, that
here was a marriage of
Penelope and Odysseus--
Odysseus gets back home and
everything's back to normal.
But the reunion of
Odysseus and Penelope
is by no means restoring
something normal.
Their marriage is establishing
a startling, unheard
of ideal of fidelity
and mutual mindedness.
Whoever had a marriage
like this man?
When Jacques Maritain
writes that poetry
is an inner communication
between the inner being
of things and the inner
being of the human self,
I think we have to take
"things" to include not only
natural ones, but
also institutions.
I could say more
about this, but I
want to move on to the
idea of what a cosmos looks
like by looking at
the ancient world,
and particularly about looking
at The Iliad and The Odyssey
next to the modern
cosmos that I think
we feel sort of atom-braided
in Hopkins' poem.
Divine presence is everywhere
in the ancient world.
In The Iliad and The Odyssey,
Zeus the cloud-gatherer
rules the sky and unpredictable
Poseidon, the sea.
Bleak Hades governs the realm
of the shades in the underworld.
And far below them lie
the halls of Tartarus,
where the ancient defeated gods
lie in their eternal bondage.
So, what is the good,
disrupt text might say,
of offering young readers
an outmoded cosmos of gods
nobody believes in,
instead of showing them
their own social circumstances
in the vernacular.
Again, there are too
many things to say.
But perhaps the most important,
is that entering an epic cosmos
keeps cultural identity
and historical circumstance
from being a prison.
If there is a
barrier of disbelief,
it's easily overcome.
And this poetic cosmos
is not closed to us
because we inhabit it with the
cues of imagination natural
to us from our own reality.
One scene from The Iliad--
there's a line in my book,
Why Literature Matters,
which ends--
well, the whole point of it is
that God loves The Iliad more
than any other poem.
This is why I keep
coming back to this.
One scene from The Iliad
will help make my point here.
At the end of book
eight, the consequences
of Achilles' withdrawal
from the fighting
have become unmistakable.
Hector has just succeeded in
driving the terrified Achaeans
back inside the wall that was
hastily constructed to protect
the ships and the shelters.
For the first time in
the war, The Achaeans
are on the defensive.
And Hector exalts in his
unprecedented success
as the Trojans stay
out on the plain
to prevent the Achaeans from
escaping in their ships.
They expect to end the long
war by the next day, which
Agamemnon on the other side had
thought earlier in the poem.
In this mood, the
citizens bring out
from the city oxen, and
fat sheep in all speed,
and also the kindly sweet wine
with food out of their houses,
while the fighting men heap
up many piles of firewood.
For all the grimness
of war, this scene
feels almost carnivalesque.
The city is wide open.
And the soldiers are
enjoying this respite
from their years trapped
inside the walls.
Homer ends this book with a
poem, with a complex simile.
Whoops.
There we go.
"So with hearts made
high these sat night-long
by the outworks of battle,
and their watchfires
blazed numerous about them.
As when in the sky the stars
about the moon's shining
are seen in all
their glory, when
the air has fallen to stillness,
and all the high places
of the hills are clear, and
the shoulders out-jutting,
and the deep ravines,
as endless bright air
spills from the heavens
And all the stars are
seen, to make glad
the heart of this shepherd;
such in their numbers blazed
the watchfires the
Trojans were burning
between the waters of Xanthos
and the ships, before Ilion.
A thousand fires were
burning in the plain,
and beside each one sat
fifty men in the glare
of the blazing firelight.
And standing each beside his
chariot, champing white barley
and oats, the horses
waited for the dawn
to mount to her high place."
I love this simile.
So, what's going on in it?
One thing that's
going on in it is
that there's a movement
of the imagination away
from the scene of
the fires far away,
to the shepherd in the hills
looking up at the stars.
I'm reminded, when I read this,
of our students at Wyoming
Catholic who go out
on a winter trip.
In fact, they just
went out last week.
And they go up into the Tetons.
And at night they do
cross-country skiing
and build their ice
houses and see these stars
with this unpolluted
sky that this shepherd,
3,000 years ago in Homer's
simile, would have seen.
Then you come back down
to the fires, which
have been immortalized in this
kind of vision of the heavens.
Then you come back to each
fire, with the light and warmth
of that fire.
And then almost like
a flash of a camera
for a second, the faces of
those 50 men around each fire.
And then the last
movement of the image
to those horses
leaning over, almost
as though the white barley were
a kind of meal of stars leaning
down to the earth.
Gaston Bachelard writes
that a particular cosmos
forms around a
particular image, as soon
as the poet gives the image
the destiny of grandeur.
The grandeur of
Homer's image pulls us
directly into the cosmos of the
poem and its unfolding drama.
These Trojans would not
be spending the night
outside the city had Zeus not
nodded his head to Achilles'
mother Thetis at
the end of book one
and promised to
give Achilles honor.
By the end of book
eight, the absence
of Achilles from the fighting
has drawn these Trojans out
onto the plain, full
of a false confidence.
Under Hector, they
enjoy this night
with hearts made high
only because they do not
imagine the return of
the warrior Achilles.
The sense of vastness, the
starry sky, the nearby ocean,
the walled city--
all these give space to the
unfolding destiny of Achilles,
the hero deprived
at his conception
of supreme immortality
and now being
given his poetic compensation.
Embedded in this moment
of Trojans celebration
are already the fires of
the destruction of Troy.
These households bringing
out their food and sweet wine
will very soon be ransacked
in the passions of war.
But for a moment,
Homer transcends
the dramatic circumstance
of war in a scene
of clarity and beauty.
And all those such moments, in
retrospect, reveal more deeply
and poignantly the
unfolding tragedy.
They also remain
in the imagination
as a promise of a more enduring
peace and a truer homeland.
The peculiarity of the
imagination is nobility,
Wallace Stevens wrote
during World War II.
In this inherent nobility is
a natural source of another,
which our extremely
headstrong generation
regards as false and decadent.
"I mean," Stevens
says, "that nobility,
which is our spiritual
height and depth," end quote.
There's nothing more
conspicuously absent
from the literature
of our own day
than the world-making
grandeur of the imagination.
We feel the urgency of
getting past hypersensitive
intersectional grievances
and trigger warnings.
But how do we begin
the ennobling recovery?
As Yeats says of the soul,
in Sailing to Byzantium,
it needs to study monuments
of its own magnificence,
these world-making
works that give us
the great characters and
actions, the enduring
metaphors.
But precisely those
are being Rejected.
So suppose we take
our cue from Achilles.
Instead of letting
our great literature
be insulted and counseled,
we deliberately withdraw it.
We deny Homer and
Shakespeare, say,
to those below a
certain income level
or those who identify
themselves as belonging
to certain social groups.
And we greatly
encourage letting them
read only things that flatter
their own current level
of knowledge.
And implicitly we forbid them
to aspire to anything else.
This is outrageous.
[SCOFFS]
But I am hard
pressed to say what
the difference is between
this program and disrupt text.
It's a pleasure to meet someone
denied the classics in college,
who comes upon
them later in life,
and can hardly believe the
extent of their earlier
deprivation.
At places like Hillsdale and
Wyoming Catholic College,
we study the great tradition
of literature in which
wisdom adds to wisdom--
The Bible, The Odyssey, The
Aeneid, The Divine Comedy,
Paradise Lost, the great
plays of Shakespeare
and others, the great
novels, the great lyrics.
We hold on to the past
because we hold on to hope.
Stevens ends his
essay, The Noble Rider
and the Sound of Words, with
a simile both of consolation
and challenge.
As a wave is a force and not the
water of which it is composed,
which is never the
same, so nobility
is a force, and not
the manifestations
of which it is composed,
which are never the same.
Nobility of spirit exists
now, as it has always existed.
And more than ever, we
need a deeper knowledge
of our great literature.
Why?
To help us cultivate an
honor in our students,
the imagination to
renew our institutions
and make a new world
from the best of the old.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
EAMMON WEED: Thank
you, Dr. Arbery.
We now have time for some
Q&A. If you have a question,
please make your way
down to the front.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for the talk.
I was wondering, do you
think that the prevalence
of superhero characters
in modern storytelling
is a result of the
deprivation of epic heroes?
GLENN ARBERY: That's
a great question.
In fact, when I was thinking
about the absence of grandeur
in literature, I'm
really thinking
more about sort of mainstream
novels and plays and so on.
While in the
popular imagination,
I guess we can call it,
there's a teaming kind
of world of superheroes and
semi-gods and so on that's
going on.
And these have huge popularity.
So even when you're
trying to get
across the nature
of the Homeric gods,
the temptation is
always to say--
OK, what's the difference
between, say, Captain America
and Iron Man or something?
What's the difference
between the kind of mutation
that leads to some
kind of superpowers
and mere technological
advantage?
But I think the impulse
is there toward some kind
of heightening, some kind
of middle way of imagining
between ordinary people and the
sort of inaccessible divine.
So yeah, I think you're
onto something there.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
As someone who,
and I'm sure there
are other people in
the room like this,
planning on teaching
in the future--
anything from elementary school
all the way up to high school
and possibly beyond--
I wanted to ask for
either a piece of advice
or how you yourself
have inhabited
these aspects of world-making
in concrete and embodied
thought in your own teaching
and in your own classes.
GLENN ARBERY: Thank you.
I think the most
important thing to do
when you're teaching
literature, and I
have to say I learned this
most of all from Louise Cowan,
is to make the students--
or to help the student imagine
what's going on in the story.
In other words, if you're always
going at a poem or a novel
in order to extract from it what
seems to you the salient idea,
you're not treating
it as literature.
You're treating it as a
kind of candy wrapper.
And down inside
is the real thing.
There are always
depths to anything
that's important in literature.
But the first thing
to do is to make
that effort of
imagination, which takes
you deeply into the story.
I remember Louise Cowan
teaching Moby-Dick when
I was a graduate assistant.
And she was treating a novel
which I had read before
but didn't like.
And suddenly, reading into
those scenes of the novel
when Ishmael and
Queequeg and Starbuck
are chasing this
huge pod of whales,
and suddenly they get
drawn into the center--
this kind of still center
where all the whales
are circling around.
And they can see
down into the depths
of the sea at the young
leviathans and their mothers.
I mean, it's just
marvelous, as soon
as you get the image,
instead of simply
concentrating on what seemed
to you the conceptual part.
I think this is true of children
as it is of college students.
That is, this is the first
thing you do, imagine
into the nature of
the world that's being
given in that work.
What's it like to inhabit
a body in that world?
I think that's important
to always think about.
In other words, when
you're reading something,
you enter it in a body.
You have a kind of fictive
body or imaginal body.
And, to the extent that
the writer is good,
you find yourself grounded
in at home in that world.
So I think that's a first
way to go with that.
Thank you, great question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for coming in to talk to us.
So being classically
educated, we
have the opportunity
to read these books
and to be helped through them.
But sometimes, because of
that, some of my favorite books
are classics.
But how do you do it when
you're no longer in school
and you're no longer being
taught these classics?
Are you doomed?
Is it once you're out of
college and are no longer
being taught the classics
you can't enjoy them?
How do you enjoy
these classic books?
GLENN ARBERY: (SARCASTICALLY)
Well, you don't.
You just go watch The Avengers.
You know?
[LAUGHTER]
No, I think having
people who also
like to read them
is pretty important.
So communities of readers, I
think, are vital to anything
that you're really going to
be able to continue to do.
It's great to read these
things on your own.
It's just, as you
say, more difficult.
I think it's easier
to read novels
than it is to read,
say, the epic poems.
But still, I think you always
long for the conversation that
goes on about these things.
Just as you talk about bosses
and colleagues and friends,
you want to talk about
the characters and actions
that you read about in this
literature, because of the way
it illuminates the
things around you.
It gives you a
different perspective
on what might have gotten stale.
If you start seeing your
friend as Clytemnestra,
you're worried.
If you start seeing
Penelope in your mother,
you know, your mother as
striking you as Penelope--
tell your dad to go home.
All right, you know.
It's been 20 years.
Go home, Dad.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming today.
So obviously when we read
these traditional books,
and the epics especially,
we're learning
from the experiences of
timeless experiences really--
and as you said, wisdom
building on wisdom.
And more modern literature,
like you were talking about,
it's somewhat blind
to that wisdom.
So it's hard to build upon
that when it isn't there
in the first place.
So how important is it for
us to maybe expose ourselves
to the more modern
literature, when
they might make the argument
as well that only reading
traditional books flatters
our own ideas, like we can say
sometimes about the other side?
GLENN ARBERY:
Excellent question.
I think we should
read everything.
I read modern novels just
as I read the classics.
In fact, you're
looking all the time,
I think, for the
work that's going
to be a breakthrough, something
that's going to really address
us in a way that is world-making
in the sense I'm speaking of.
We need writers who
aren't just trying
to undercut everything that's
good about the tradition,
but really try to remake
it to see how to take it
into a different
social circumstance,
political circumstance.
What do you do in a world
where not everybody believes
in God in the same way
that Dante's world did?
How do you establish
that relation
between the human
and the divine that's
so crucial to understanding
what it feels like to be
in the Homeric world?
Right?
Where are we finding that done?
So I think reading modern
literature is always
a kind of urging
of modern writers
to take up this
challenge and to really
try to see what that would
be like if you reintroduce
the divine, say, into novels.
I like the way you put that.
Why aren't we just saying that
we're flattering ourselves
by reading these same things?
Part of my point,
and this is something
I wish I could have gotten into
a little bit more in the paper,
is that great
literature is always
taking those institutions that
we want to hold up as permanent
and unchanging and melting them
down, rebuilding them, seeing
how they can sustain the
kind of challenge that say,
Dante gives to the Church
by putting Popes in hell.
Right?
You're putting-- and then
having the Pope currently
in hell say, oh, I thought
you were the next one.
I was kind of waiting for him.
Dante is scathing in his
criticism of the Church.
But he's doing it in order to
try to restore the institution,
same thing with politics, right,
same thing with marriages.
We need to constantly
be thinking
how to renew the inner
being of these institutions,
just as we try to renew
the world around us
with metaphor and such things.
Thank you for that question.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
So I was wondering
what you thought
of film adaptations of
these great classical works,
like those of
Shakespeare or Homer.
I mean, obviously something is
lost going from page to screen
and they often take
some liberties.
But on the other
hand, it's a way
of exposing a more
casual audience who
wouldn't read those
books naturally
to those great stories.
So do you think there's
a value in that?
GLENN ARBERY: Absolutely.
In fact, I think--
I'll probably draw
criticism for this.
But I think we're in a great age
of a certain form of depiction.
It's more or less like
the serialized novel.
Some of the series, like
The Wire or Breaking Bad,
you raise your eyebrows.
But these are pretty
major accomplishments.
And I think when you can
serialize great books
in a way that doesn't
diminish, again,
the character of the world
that's being depicted in those,
I think it's a great service.
It might tell us that we're
back in an oral culture.
I don't know.
But it's not that
Shakespeare's works are written
to be handed out to readers.
They're presented as
works in the theater.
And there's a lot of
speculation about why
Shakespeare himself
never even bothered
to edit them for publication.
So that kind of presentation,
film, all these things, I think
is part of what gets
these works across.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much for
coming to speak to us today.
A lot of modern
education will require
reading some of these
more challenging books
like The Scarlet
Letter and The Odyssey
and everything like that.
But a lot of
students will end up
just Spark Notesing it
or not even bothering
to read it at all.
And a lot of authors
are just coming up
with interesting plots that
don't ask the big questions.
So how would you say
we change the attitude
from trying to find the
instant gratification
and the entertaining
part of these stories,
to asking the bigger questions
and changing our perspectives?
GLENN ARBERY: Good question.
That's kind of "the"
question right now, isn't it?
I think you--
I'm suggesting it at the
end of my talk, well,
you just forbid
them to read them.
That'll do it.
You may not read
The Scarlet Letter.
You will never understand it.
It's too risque-- you
know, or whatever.
There's a way that I think
the real loss we face--
and I think this is in large
part because of the way
that we spend our time
on virtual media, cell
phones, and internet--
is just simply the loss of
the power of concentration.
So how to encourage that--
at Wyoming Catholic
we forbid cell phones.
You may not have a
cell phone while you're
a student at Wyoming
Catholic College.
In other words,
no, you don't get
to have it when you go
back to your dorm room.
You don't have one.
I mean, that's almost
like a gesture.
But it's a gesture in the
direction of concentration,
of the capacity
to take some time
and to sink into
something in a way that
allows you to experience
the language of it
and those deeper questions
that naturally arise from it.
It's also good to have people
around you in your classes
who care deeply
about these things
and push you so that
it's not something
that you can easily skate over.
Yeah, the Spark Notes
world of literature, that's
the great enemy.
Thank you
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Dr. Arbery.
I was just curious.
It seems like the modern
preoccupation with literature
is--
and the reason that they
dismiss the classics
is that everyone is
preoccupied with feelings.
And so the modern
authors, they try
to get us to try
and feel something
and not so much to
think about something.
How would you try to make the
argument to the modern thought
that where a well-formed
person should
cry at the end of
The Divine Comedy,
with the image of the divine?
That should be something
that you should have feelings
toward.
GLENN ARBERY: There's
a chapter in my book,
Why Literature Matters, called
the "Intelligence of Feeling."
And the premise of it is that
well-formed feelings contain
a great deal of experience and
a great deal of thought that's
gone into what people have
done in what you've read
and in what you've
experienced in your own life.
I look to feeling as a pretty
strong key to the truth
of things, if it's well formed.
So I don't want to
dismiss feeling.
On the other hand, this
appeal to sentiment,
I thought what Roger
Kimball said last night
about sentiment was dead on.
There's a kind of
sentimentality of fake emotion,
in a lot of what we see
now, that isn't earned,
it isn't part of
what would naturally
unfold from the actions and
circumstances of a work.
You appeal to a certain kind
of cultural trope or meme,
and that's supposed
to be sufficient.
It's a cue-- cry here.
Whereas the truly deep
works, like King Lear
when Cordelia comes
out in Lear's arms
at the end of that play--
If you're not feeling
anything there,
there's something deeply wrong.
So, great question, thank you.
EAMMON WEED: We now have
time for one more question.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for speaking.
I have a question about-- you
mentioned that literature helps
form us and helps give us
the proper dispositions
that we should
have towards life,
and that classical
literature is useful
or takes a large part in
forming us in that way.
Do you think that modern,
or some modern literature,
can be a deformation or be
antithetical to that process?
And then, should we
avoid reading things
that do participate in
a deformation process?
And then how do we avoid
those malevolent works?
GLENN ARBERY: Again,
an important question.
I think it's hard to
know in advance what
a work is going to do to you.
I worry about this.
I worry about students
who have moral qualms,
say, about reading
Madame Bovary.
They're scared they're going
to be tempted in some way.
You're going to be tempted
toward much worse literature
if you don't read it.
I think that it's
difficult to judge
what's deforming if you
haven't been formed, right?
And if you have
been formed, I don't
think that the
danger of deformation
is going to be very powerful.
So, I mean, we know certain
things are deforming.
Pornography is deforming, right?
But an honest attempt to give a
kind of vision of the world we
live in through literature
doesn't seem to me deforming,
unless we are conscious from
the outset that as Keats says,
it has a design
on you; that it's
trying to get you to
do something or think
a certain way.
If it's an honest attempt to
depict the world that we live
in and the characters
who live in it,
I think you have to
risk a little bit.
Good question,
though, thank you.
And thank you all.
I appreciate it.
EAMMON WEED: Thank
you, Dr. Arbery.
[APPLAUSE]